yeah welcome to this video forum game
for the World Championship match in
chennai india we've seen three drawers
so far but game three really was a
proper interesting chess game and let's
see what happened today in Game four are
not began playing wide and he is going
for before again his some longtime main
move and done cousin who actually had
surprised an island in Game two with c6
no place in five is made with against
the king pawn opening so we get ruined
Oh pass and here Carlton has played
mostly a6 going for main line Ruis black
the Brier for example or some Bishop c5
lines he has played more than one system
but of course they also is the Berlin
defense to that to the boy and this is
what Carlton plate not a new system he
has mean for his opening repertoire yes
played this before and okay any year for
player on the top level nowadays needs
to have something prepared against the
villain it's really getting difficult
for white again again again and again to
um yeah to try to break through this
this Berlin Wall okay almond has castle
and he has always prepare a preferred
that going for the Berlin endgame of
course they also sd3 yes played this as
well but he has quite good results in
the end game so after castles 94 d 4 +
96 when this night had text the bishop
why it takes on 26 and we get the check
infamous Berlin Wall endgame this
position was played numerous times in
the World Championship match in two
thousand turn between Kasparov and crumb
neck and chronic managed to manage to
draw all black games in this in this
opening which was them really the
foundation of his title win against
Kasparov he basically blunted when he
formed by the world champion and here
again in a world championship game we
see this this end game where Carson has
the black pieces and yeah it's not
necessarily trying to play for a draw
it's just an opening that really fits
his style I would say it's a position
with Queens of the board we're very
often strategical maneuvering is is
important so this kind of position is
certainly to his liking and I played
rugby warning check no first Ashley I'm
sorry but he pledged what you want here
he delayed the move Knight c3 this is a
later development I'm I mean the last
couple of month this move ordered gained
some popularity before that everybody
was playing Knight c3 year after which
black him as a choice he can now play
all kinds of move Bishop d7 um kingi 897
and so on and white very often later
place look do you want at some point at
age three but the idea of d'Alene Knight
c3 is that white actually gains a bit of
time from play on the King side here
after look T one console plays Bishop to
here mostly King c8 has been seen before
which after g4 needs to position that
has been played a number of times
recently and this is actually quite
sharp right now can go for quick inside
the tech 95 who should be age and F
phone yeah very sharply and wide really
tries to knock out like on the King side
gaining much space and at the moment
black has some quite sufficient results
here but very likely am honored that his
team have they found some interesting
new idea carlo played but should be sent
which shouldn't really be a surprise to
to honor because this move has been
played three times already via jean-luc
the camel which who is Carlton second
and yeah former schoolmate and very good
GM himself 2600 yellow rating and yeah
they worked together for for basically
all their chests life so on his game
suddenly were very high on the list of
games to check but strangely enough on
are not really quickly now gets into
some trouble we'll see what happens see
now plays Knight c3 hard to do without
the move in the long run King c8 yeah
getting at the King out of the default
very logical and Bishop to g5 yeah this
isn't that yeah that is some quite
interesting black of course has got the
two bishops which is of course an S
some compensation for the double pawns
but on the other hand this Bishop only
seven quite often is a problematic piece
especially if you want to play c5 at
some point c5 and Bishop c6 for example
can be an idea to activate the d7 bishop
and maybe with the pawn on c5 use the
divorce Square and what I'm getting at
is if you want to play or if you play c5
you would really kill this Bishop on a
seven that's always biting on this pawn
so what this exchange is something that
has also some positive effects of like
it's not all good for wide we see him
that after each six and trade yeah now
look d2 also quite obvious move using
the default in the game in manual back
against the jungle via my a4 was played
and we see that after this Bishop c6 was
blacks idea and in fact the game
relatively quickly ended in a draw this
does not really seemed to threaten some
black position much yeah wookie to is
the world champions move c5 and look a
truly one term I guess after Bishop to
e6 we get to an important point it seems
that here are mountain didn't really
find or choose the the right plan
because the tables really quickly now
turned to blacks favor he played 91
their DM could be something like that
and this kind of real ooping it's quite
similar
to what we will see in the game this
looks weird okay the night wants to go
to d3 this watch is clear but it's not
easy at all if you look at this 96 it
takes the pot and now it's a bit tricky
what should I play if i visit act if you
play night d3 here then b6 this poster
this was the game of course and and what
now what now exactly like is intending
to play c4 and then just grab the e5
pawn and it's not not so easy to react
to that for example if you play b3 just
mechanically trying to combat the c
forum move black of course will play C
for anyway and the line like this is
just slightly better for black because
he's got a bishop this Bishop is
stronger than then a night in this
position as it's getting opened up also
there's a non-symmetrical confirmation
in the works two pawns against three
pawns and also very important white
actually has some weaknesses f4 for
example and almost all pawns are weak
while black spots are nicely positioned
far away from White's camp and without
offering any bigger weaknesses so this
does not really help this be through
them I'm not sure how I should defend an
ant choose them I think from a practical
point of view a good a good move he
played 92 just ignoring the fact that
this Bishop is looking at da to pawn
and he just concentrates on the renewing
ideas that he has and young cousin just
just took the point it's it's funny it
really reminds you of this famous famous
first match game Spassky against
official official grab the h2porn and
lost the bishop afterwards and this is
not comparable situation and as Maxum
Bishop can get out rather quickly of
course White's idea was to to trap the
bishop this is the only move to cause
any problems and after c4 he went for 91
yeah attacking the stranded piece black
can take on b3 of course and white here
just recaptured attacking the bishop
twice it needs to go to be one otherwise
it's gone and here played f4
yeah the bishops are very exposed but
not attacked at the moment now his
attacked needs to go to f5 and now g4
yeah white ass can't have quite a number
of Tempe after his yeah hot sacrifice
eyelids and the press conference
admitted that he had somehow miss played
the opening and wasn't quite some
trouble at this stage simply because if
you look at the position you are pretty
quickly I think get the impression let's
just put this on the ball to have the
game position where for is protected it
looks they're very yeah very nice for
white actually like is got some decent
compensation for the pawn but the
problem on the other hand is it might be
compensation if it's sufficient not
quite sure but it's it might be
compensation the problem is however that
very easily if you make a second-rate
move and jam the defender here black
manages to consolidate and yeah simply
not who you are getting mated of London
material back then black has excellent
winning chances also because of the
better structure and the end the bishop
so on this is now struggle between
whites activity and blacks a desire to
simplify the position to get a very good
endgame so what exactly is White's
compensation here even if it might not
be one hundred percent sufficient on
white enjoys active pieces he's got
those nights ready to near yet to go
near the King and support
those an advanced pawns and also of
course White has got both looks into
play and this cannot really be set oops
about blacks looks and yeah this is
pretty much them reasoning behind the
next couple of moves h5 is played using
the rook on its initial square black has
no um ya know one good IDM to worm to a
pose on the D file for example you go
movie eight that's just thought night's
fire but everyone saying so this first
is the more precise means if you play
this check there's a poor name even this
is quite good for white good first f5
after th is stronger pushing the night
back car move as much better just h5
using the look on its initial square f5
of course pushing the pawns and 97 here
let H form also could could be
considered but 97 is just much more
natural move but this prettily to a
quite funny complication let's say
complications let's say King f2 and g6
here why it has an interesting way to
gain counter play this is luke c1 using
it on the C file and if we look at this
the point is that white attacks with 95
and then this exact position it's not so
easy to defend black basically needs to
play c5 there's no other move and then
reform just ripping open the Queen side
after a line like that check of the line
like that the computers completely
unimpressed and gives black slight edge
but this is some position that the human
really has a hard time to assess because
of those the advanced pieces and I
didn't really know it's very tricky to
play and they're very understandable
that cows didn't allow any of that I
think he simply trust this instinct that
the night should help to defend on the
queenside instead of just going to H
form
yeah ip5 this prepares this attack
against the seven and also allows the
redeployment of the night on reform so
simply simply logical move I think Carla
took on g4 in fact if you look at this
kind of position with computer help then
you can quickly come to the conclusion
that probably first a six work better
simply because it makes things a bit
more straightforward Dwight probably
needs to retreat and then you take on g4
if you want in the game immediately took
the ends now in this position wyd
actually had a funny opportunity that is
yeah as so often difficult to spot he M
had the additional option to play rook
see one here taking on c7 black doesn't
have much choice he needs to cover it on
mercy seven soul 95 plate and here
there's the quite quite amazing actually
quite amazing idea to continue the
attack with v6 so after ft-86 this
Knight e5 and now we're in the territory
where it's very unlikely that any human
player would find this would find this
awesome yes white this position is in
fact very funny because they are even
some some meeting ID sem if black plays
a move that doesn't change the position
at all i just want to show the threat
let's say up jade
and white can sacrifice on c7 the point
being that Knight takes Knight chessex
check qbh checkmate leads to a very
funny type of smothered mate that you
really see very rarely very nice mate
and instead King a6 of courses check
nate is also made a less cute one but
still a nice mate group c7 a thread so
black IAM should react to that at one
good replies a5 giving the black king
some sam boom and after let's say cakes
and c5 the game simply continues black
has two were two extra bones but why it
has lots of activity it's not clear at
all I think Roxy one was a very viable
alternative but he decided for something
else he just recaptured we're just not
not bad i was just i just thought that
rook see one is worth mentioning because
it's a look-see to it's very similar
it's worth mentioning because of this
interesting group takes c7 idea yeah
here is some get another critical
position of this game on auntie em
played the most loop 2h form not without
the logic of course it's just attacking
move against the g4 porn and it does not
really spoil much but it seems that a
6am was probably the more promising way
to play after 90 for the logical retreat
that is a five and
need to play a 4 and this is quite funny
black hair suffers from coordination
issues especially the looks didn't
participate in the game and now black
with the help of h 5 and the capture he
has activated his look on a jade and now
he's trying to play a 5a for activating
the head book or maybe even to the first
rank so it's quite nice how black
activates pieces it's a well possible
that this was the the easier
continuation after the rook news of
course 9 f 2 is plate and then 96 this
was thousands idea to activate the
nygean try to get counter play against
the db5 Bomb Group C 2 of course keeping
in mind the pressure on c7 and now a 5-4
plate with the same already mentioned
idea to activate the look in this way
there are alternatives instead of a 5
black also could have played the g6
immediately also not bad at all and it
can lead to very crazy complications for
example if you look at this movie to see
one Bishop to d7 and now the funny move
Knight deform it's very interesting at
first it looks exactly the same but it
is quite interesting the idea is out of
the capture check takes here that
amazingly after Luke takes d7 check
it's a g2 just a second I need to look
at my notes no can you have one of
course takes and now the funny bone idle
for a while why does the whole look down
the position is not completely clear one
the point is 96 and then would be 7
checkmate not forced at all but it shows
that there are some tricks in this
position in fact I continued this line a
bit longer 85 group takes on f7 I think
yea TX and 96 and it seems that at the
end White has got enough count to play 2
to level the game I have made some
further analysis moves here but this
would mean to present and almost 29 with
deep line which pretty much for sure has
got some some quality issues long a long
line wrong line since old saying
attributed usually to bend Larson yeah
this would have been a very crazy
continuation but as mentioned on and
after after a five was played and not a
g6 and now on I'd play group C for some
a bit surprising smooth but it makes
sure that this rook works nicely on the
fourth rank and back cannot easily play
a 5a for two to three himself and now
contemplate g6 yeah quite a logical move
again fighting against those pawns and
what would be forced to a move
the earth porn for example taking here
then black gap gains lots of scope for
the bishop so this is not the way to go
of course on a plate whoopsie one first
taking on c6 after Bishop d7 he played
e6 pushing as pawns so this majority has
traveled quite a long way now to e6
we've gone on the sixth-ranked to to get
counter play and now Bishop to gate so
we see that white is a pawn down of
course but he's got lots of activity all
those pretty active plus there's the e6
pond which also is potentially strong
and now the next move is very very
important and the only move if you
analyze it a little bit deeper the only
moves that keeps right into into the
game on yeah keeps widen business and
this game played very strong with 94 as
yeah like so often the best defense is
an attacking moving aggressive move and
not to move that simply yeah that's
nothing and try to defend passively it
of course gives up the default born and
the magnus just took a check i think
it's just a practical decision to bonds
is quite a lot so black it's two pawns
up now which also means that at the
right moment you can always consider to
sacrifice an exchange and get to an
ending where you have quite quite a
number of pawns so when we see this is
an important motif now of course white
plate king f2 while
and here exactly here this position
probably am black had the opportunity to
yet to make something out of his
advantage it's clear that like is the
one that is going to win the game with
anything if whites active defense faults
um like a the favored to win but it's so
difficult to play it seems that here the
best move from is route 38 it looks a
very logical but only after the game it
does it come see you the idea is to
activate look in this way I'm a possible
line to put it on the board this line
now king of three and here black cam has
a funny year a funny way to simplify the
position you can take here after route
takes you can take on e6 it's quite
quite funny the idea being that after
who takes Nigel check and 19 36 black
has a very very good angle this is one
of the AUSA and games that i mentioned
before where you get a number of pawns
for the exchange and of course only
black and wind and this position here
and he has got pretty decent winning
chances i think that may be exactly this
point this rook da truth was where
Magnus um yeah letter on an out out a
bit and I defended very actively very
nicely I think but what the aid is
probably the way to go in to make me win
the game chat you played this check and
return to FA
and now White has the golden opportunity
and he finds it 94 intensifying the
pressure here so black basically has no
choice he needs to grab the night check
who takes King to a 6 and King takes d4
so why it has some with this operation
starting on move 35 activated his pieces
enormously just to have a look him to do
it this way to pieces that are passive
and white managers by giving up one
point checked evade the king check and
reach this position on new 40 white is
still upon down but he's got the very
very strong e6 porn notoriously
dangerous black skin is slightly exposed
on a six it's not like a mating attack
but you can often use tricks against
such an unstable King on the side of the
board check whoop d 8 was played here
and I'm not now playing King c3 the
computer wants to play King III and says
all right this is equal but it's very
likely that after King c3 it's a draw
anyway and this is because what now
happens this simplification into her um
yeah first double rook endgame and Anna
pure endgame a pop you look and game
it's very difficult to to avoid all that
if you look at this position Blackwater
activating his rook this is some quite
quite normal looking and here there's
not much else Luke CA displayed and this
forces further trades
yeah first first would be 3 by this
one-on-one we have the straight of the
the minor pieces and the strong form as
mentioned only seven is saving the day
white can always trade the e pawn
against the gphone under favorable
circumstances and then draw the endgame
in fact this is exactly what happened
check book trade us an instant draw this
is just taking a bit of time but we get
to get to this check no White's trying
to prepare the promotion but like has
everything under control channels check
yeah a couple of checks cat not too much
happening besides this move you can
sometimes yeah relax too early and this
is exactly one of those positions
positions karl has just played rookie
six and what happens if white takes the
porn hmm in fact this is a big mistake
because of b5 and this threatens be form
which is completely deadly it just got
made slide I'm very difficult to do
anything against it black is on minus
five already so rookie six was a final
little trap that you can easily fall
into if you relax too early if you give
this to a good player he will recognize
the b5 idea but sometimes you don't look
for ideas you just say okay this is over
and play moves but they always need to
be cautious and check the most important
things so we am at the end get this this
end game check there's no no room for
any improvement basically I tried yeah
one pair
books down and white got the beach
reform yeah here draw was the grid um
they didn't play it out too bad Kings
which we are good if possible if you
really want to spend more time on the
board all over the board then then
necessary this is a very trivial draw
just in case you don't know the drawing
mechanism and there's more than one but
with the beep one like this and the Jeep
on there is an even simpler way than or
the simplest way of all here is to just
put the King on g1 and the loop on the
first rank and then simply do nothing
and at the end draw the game because the
other side didn't get anywhere i can put
that on the board if you like just to to
show the general idea i'm just playing
some passing moves king before of course
not sorry ok so now you can you can
start to once yeah this is all that
black and manage and simply the rope
covering the first rank prevents black
from giving any sort of check and this
position is simply completely dead
completely dead wrong one of many
drawing lines against the B&G porn so at
the end a draw again the fourth draw in
a row but not a draw that merits or
deserves any criticism a great fight
where aunt got in some pretty
substantial trouble how in the opening
he tried to sort of ignore all that
sacrifice a pawn to get active play and
of course it it brought him
some activity which at the end after 94
very strong move was enough to draw the
game probably cards missed something 36
rook t8 was a good alternative and also
instead of rook h4 there was a six at
this point maybe slightly more precise
so there were chances for the Challenger
in this game clearly but we also see
that honor this not in bad shape error
on finding moves like 94 and defending
precisely under that kind of pressure
that he was under from quite early on in
the game I hope you enjoyed the video
I'll be back or let me think about it on
friday with the game five coverage
thanks for watching